isis state versus marisol
charge conference the indictments
1912-00999-8 and i have appearances of
council good morning honorably please
support christopher schaltman for the
state
good morning your honor alexander
bennett on behalf of the state
edwards
and christopher dininger here on behalf
of michael barissa all right morning
everyone mr barristone is his present
wearing a blue shirt and a
blue and light blue striped tie
right this is a charge conference in
this case
so
let me first run through i have a rough
draft very rough draft of the charge so
i'll run through for everyone
my initial thoughts on the charge and
then i'll hear from
council
regarding any additions
because if i if i may i just want to put
on the record that i make a motion uh at
the end of the case i don't believe
there's sufficient grounds to uh present
the case to the jury so okay
all right understood
um anything you want to say with regard
to that mr shellhorn
i think the record speaks for itself the
motion won't be denied there is
sufficient evidence as i said
after the completion of the state's case
and
taking into account everything that's
been presented i think there is
very clearly sufficient evidence for
accounts warning count two charging
attempt and murder and counts three and
four charging possession of a weapon
namely a handgun for an unlawful purpose
the motion will be denied
all right with regard to the charge
most of these are from the
model jury charges
core relate general information
the nature of the indictment itself
presumption of innocence burden of proof
reasonable doubt
function of the court
judges questioning uh function of the
jury
direct and and then that's the first
part now the second part
of the instructions deals with specific
evidence
oh i give the standard charge on direct
and circumstantial evidence the standard
charge on credibility of witnesses to
stand to charge false in one false at
all
stand a charge on uh statements of the
defendant
although i did um
the the standard charge requires the
court to address some specifics
so the jury knows what the court's
talking about
um
so as i recall there were statements
from um related statements by corporal
derek heimer
relating
the defendant stated at the scene i had
a good life repeatedly stated i had a
good life
also police officer hensley testified
that while defendant was in an ambulance
he stated quote is this real i need to
wake up
it was his testimony that that was
repeated mr shellhorn if you recall
my recollection is that it was yesterday
is that your recollection mr blencus yes
but that was his testimony
and detective gould testified at the
hospital while the defendant was in the
icu unit
he heard the uh defendant
stated and i'm going to use the term in
sum and substance because
that's the detective didn't use that
term
but he didn't relate it word for word
like the other
two witnesses so in summon substance he
said
they destroyed my life over the past six
months i had a good life they took it
all away
and
that he was sorry
and then the charge relates to
consideration of circumstances facts as
how the statement was made
um specifically about
the standard george directs
reference to miranda so i will indicate
that hensley testified
he advised defender of his miranda
rights from a court he carried officer
hensley testified the defendant verbally
acknowledged his miranda rights but did
not recall
whether defendant indicated he wished to
speak to the officer
there was also testimony induced from
various witnesses regarding the
defendant's physical injuries
and mental status at the time
then i go on the end of that particular
charge if consideration
if at the consideration of all these
factors you determine the statement was
not actually made or the statement is
not credible then you must disregard the
statement completely
if you find a statement was made
statements
you find the statements were made
and that part
for all of the statements are credible
you must give what weight you think
appropriate to the portion of the
statement you find to be truthful and
credible
um the defendant's election not to
testify i'm assuming you want that mr
belinkus
mr dynger
okay
um
then there are limiting instructions
i i think
one of the witnesses did reference the
defendant being in jail
so
just out of an abundance of caution i'm
going to include that charge unless i
hear any objection no i i think it
wasn't explicitly really talked about
but it was well the experts didn't do
that yes
um but
and i i think it may have been
i'm trying to remember i'll go through
my notes over the weekend but i i do
recall a witness said it it wasn't
specifically asked but it but it came
out it may have been dr simmering that
said it
my recollection is that it first came
out with one of those witnesses that the
defense called who works at the jail yes
and indicated that's right the
psychiatrist at the jail yes and then it
did come up through the experts i think
it was dr simran and dr hassan mentioned
reviewing jail records or something of
that nature but i think it would just
make the record clear rejection
all right so i'm just going to say uh
during the testimony of certain
witnesses
um i'm not planning on indicating which
witnesses unless you want me to i don't
see a need for that you want me to
mention the specific witness or just a
general reference
during the testimony of certain
witnesses mate
they may have made reference to the fact
that information
was obtained from the defendant while he
was in custody at the morris county jail
and that's specifically referring to the
jail psychiatrist
um
the fact that the defendant was detained
in this facility at some point is
irrelevant and should play no part in
your consideration of this case you may
not use this evidence in any way to
infer that the defendant is guilty of
the charges simply because he may have
been in custody at some point in the
past
i don't want to reference that he's
still in custody that would only
emphasize the point so
and the the i think that the i forget
the gentleman's name who testified the
jail psychiatrist
i think he said it was shortly after the
incident
so that's why the wording is as it is i
don't want to tell them that he's
currently in jail but at some point
that's why i use the phrase at some
point in time is there any objection to
the wording council
and then go on from there
some at some point to me indicates that
he was let out or
again
well i wanted to avoid speculation that
he's either in jail or out of jail and
why was he let out and why is he still
in jail that's why i said at some point
to try to
obfuscate the issue but if you want it
some other way you tell me what you want
and i'll put it in at some point
and whether he's in jail or not
currently is not an issue correct i mean
it's not it's not evidence one way or
the other
and obviously shouldn't be commented on
that
during summations
all right so i'll just say the fact that
the defendant was detained in this
facility is irrelevant should play no
part in your consideration of the case
you may not use this evidence in any way
or further the defendant is guilty
on the charges simply
because
um he was in custody because i i say
again he may have been in custody at
some point in the past you want me to
take that out and just say doing further
defended guilty of charge simply because
he
was in custody
all right
all right the limiting instruction use
of drugs by
lauren canorack and robert goodwin
i referenced that
again without specifics as to the
witnesses because there were multiple
references to it having used drugs in
the past the testimony was admitted by
the court for a limited purpose
testimony may only be considered for the
limited purpose of explaining or
supporting the conclusions reached by dr
simmering dr hassan
i'm not sure schlesinger mentioned it i
don't recall it coming up when he
testified
or for assessing the value of the
doctors
opinions that are dependent or rely on
misinformation you may not consider this
testimony for any other purpose should
not consider the testimony as
substantive evidence relating to the
guilt or innocence of the defendant or
consider it as reflecting the bad
character
of lauren cataract or robert goodwin
any objection to that charge no judge
no
limiting instruction with regard to the
prior criminal history
you have heard testimony regarding the
purported and unverified criminal prior
criminal history of robert goodwin and
lauren cataract that the defendant
received from private investigator
joseph it's blatler right that was the
pi yeah joseph blatler
i believe that's true
he received similar information from cat
parkinson but you ruled it out
our defendant alleged this information
had an impact on his state of mind
i'm not sure i want to insert that in
there
that was in your
request
i'm not sure because it
saying the defendant alleges
you know sort of comments in in a
roundabout way he hasn't alleged
anything directly because he didn't
testify so i don't want to
i'm a little concerned with that
reference
can i hear the rest of the yes of course
charge judge thank you so defendant
alleged that's i haven't um putting it
in brackets because i'm not sure i
instruct you that this testimony
testimony may only be considered for the
limitless purpose of explaining or
supporting the conclusions reached by dr
simmering
and dr hasana for assessing the value of
the doctor's opinions that are dependent
or rely on this information
would your honor consider using the
defense alleges instead of the defendant
alleges
yeah i could do that
i i like the reference to the
defendant's state of mind because that's
what we're talking about here
you have any problem substituting
defense for defendant no i think that's
that makes sense
that was why i i had suggested that
language less to put some onus on the
defendant before right on yes no because
i i think it you know from the outset it
focuses the jury on the fact that the
issue is a defendant's state of mind yes
and that's why it was admitted so far to
read after the introductory line from
the private investigator joseph blatler
the defense alleges
this information had an impact on
defendant's state of mind
by the defense uh alleges this
information
i could say had an impact or affected
it may be more consistent with the rest
of the jury charge on insanity to stay
affected yeah
the defense alleges this information
affected defendant's state of mind i
instruct you that this testimony may
only be considered for the limited
purpose of explaining or supporting the
conclusions reached by dr simmering and
dr hassan regarding defendant state of
mind or
for assessing the value of the doctor's
opinions that are dependent or rely on
this information
and i go on to explain under the rules
of evidence the jury may consider a
witness's criminal conviction
in determining the credibility or
believability of that witness however
there is no evidence that lauren
cataract or robert goodwin have criminal
convictions you must not consider
testimony related to the alleged prior
criminal history as affecting the
credibility of lauren cataract or robert
goodwin nor may you consider it as
substantive evidence related to the
guilt or innocence of the defendant the
only relevance of the evidence
is the extent to which you find it
affected the mental state or mental
condition of the defendant
all right with that mr shelmore yes you
are thanks mr blinkis yes
can i give a limiting instruction on
testimony related to miss canorax
owning a firearm
that instruction reads you have heard
reference to lauren canorack owning or
possessing a firearm this testimony was
admitted by the court for a limited
purpose
his testimony may only be considered for
the limited purpose of explaining or
supporting the conclusions reached by dr
simmering dr hassan
and i think dr schlesinger made
reference to it
i believe he did make reference
to that judgment regarding the
defendant's state of mind or for
assessing the value with the doctor's
opinions that are dependent or rely on
this information you may not consider
this testimony for any other purpose
should not consider this testimony as
substantive evidence related to the
guilt or innocence of the defendant or
considerate
consider it as reflecting the bad
character of lauren cataract
no objection
all right and then the last limiting
instruction would be on the mental
health diagnosis
i'm not sure was there any specific
testimony about the
mental health diagnosis i know there was
reference on cross-examination to some
of the postings multiple personalities i
wasn't going to get that granular with
regard to the charge just generally
you have heard reference in certain
testimony
regarding the mental a mental health
diagnosis
well i don't know
that sounds like there was a formal
diagnosis and i'm not sure there was i
agree with the way it came out judge
obviously there was more information in
the reports that didn't come out during
trial so when i submitted that i didn't
know what the testimony would be but i
would agree that really the crux of it
was the post
and and i would suggest that it's not
appropriate to give the limited
instruction based on what was in that
post
your honor you don't want it at all
that's fine no
your honor we have a limiting
instruction that i believe touches upon
this uh if i can approach and give you a
copy the word it
in that instruction refers to with leave
evidence like this
i've already shown it to mr shelton
what do you want this for
specifically
we want limiting instructions so that
the jury understands
what could be considered substantive
evidence relating to guilt or innocence
in a sense
rather than something that's just
tending to support or not support
an expert's ultimate conclusion
and also that they be instructed about
the
appropriate value of opinions
when there is
independent proof
i don't believe there's an objection
from mr sheldon except we need to
flesh out the word hit
i
i think my but i guess my question is
but you know we have a number of
limiting
instructions here
my understanding here judge was that
this related more to the defendant's
statements and that the defendant's
statements to the doctors should not be
considered as substitutions
but there are other statements he made
that came out that should not be
considered substantively i think and i
assume that council will not make that
argument in closing that the statements
to the doctor are substantive but just
that those are offered for the effect
that it had on his state of mind as the
doctors uh opined about right so
there's a
there's a part of the standard expert
testimony charge
so after
so you don't want the mental health
diagnosis charge right
do you have any objection to having that
excluded
no you don't
all right so after those then i give the
standard expert testimony charge
and i have the expert witnesses i want
to identify them specifically it's
detective andreas
is a hierapolis
i'm going to have to practice that over
the weekend mr shellhorn can you come up
with an expert with a different last
name easier to pronounce a shorter
number of syllables perhaps you'll have
to talk to sheriff cannon about that
like something like william stitt i can
handle
is that hieropolis i i can tell you
right now i'm gonna stumble over that
theopolis is a common name i know right
no that's why
judge everyone calls him detective z so
i don't think he'd be offended if you
wanted to refer to him as detective z
well if i stumble over it more than once
that's when i'm going to fall back on
detective z
stitt
stephen s simmering md charles s hassan
phd and louis b
schlesinger
phd were called as
experts anyone else did i miss anyone
i don't think so
and i'll call it's dr hassan and doctor
schlesinger and then i'll
mention the phd at the end so
we'll go through that there's a standard
charge but then there's a limiting
instruction regarding the hearsay
statements of the defendant
and it's similar to what
council gave me
and it says you have heard reference
to alleged statements made by the
defendant in the course
of psychiatric examinations
you should not consider these hearsay
statements as substantive evidence
related to the guilt or innocence of the
defendant
or for the truth of the matter asserted
by the defendant in the statement rather
i instruct you to consider these
statements only for a limited purpose of
explaining or supporting the conclusions
of doctors so and so and so and so or
assessing the value of the doctor's
opinions so you would rather instead of
that instruction you want the court to
provide this limiting instruction
yes okay do you have any objection to
that
i don't see an issue with what's in the
standard
charge uh but
i think this essentially says
at least if it's uh
tailored to indicate that it's talking
about the defendant's statements
let me just relate back to the hearsay
aspect
i think the issue i have with the second
paragraph on what's been provided is
that it talks about the opinion hinging
on the truth of the matter asserted and
i don't know that there's anything that
the doctors testified to
that hinged on the truth of the matter
it was just on things like i'm not sure
there was anything that hints on the
truth it's not
um
it goes to his state of mind it's it's
whether he believed it or not not
whether it was true or not
and that goes like that goes
that that's
the same as any other state of mind
no statements are um
let in not for the truth of the matter
asserted but because of the impact they
had on
the hearer
and if they took some action as a result
of hearing that statement for instance
it would still come in but not for the
truth of the matter so
i'm not sure
the opinions of any of the doctors
relied on the truth of the matter
asserting you're all right
go ahead
i think uh with regards to any
evaluations
when when an individual tells the doctor
certain things
if there's independent verification
that that he
is able to look at and document
i i think
he takes that and i think the doctors
indicated takes that into consideration
with regards to things the
person is telling him and what whether
or not you should believe him all the
doctor says that really don't take the
defendants
what they tell them at face value you
have to review the discovery see what
is in there and if it can be documented
what he tell
is telling you the truth i think that
has an impact on
whether he believes him whether he's
being honest and so forth so i think
that's a general statement well
it's
the the truth of the matter
asserted
you can view it a number of different
ways that's and part of my concern with
this is
the first part
the statements because it reads you have
heard reference alleged statements made
by the defendant in the course of
psychiatric examinations
then i would put
those statements should not be not
instead of it we're referring to those
statements those statements should not
be considered by the jury as substantive
evidence related to the guilt or
innocence of the accused but only as
evidence tending to support the ultimate
expert conclusion of the psychiatrist on
the question of insanity
so
a lot of this is contained in the
standard charge because it says
it is always within the special function
of the jury to determine whether the
facts on which the answer or testimony
of an expert is based actually exists
the value or weight of the opinion of
the expert is dependent on
and is no stronger than the facts on
which it is based
in other words the prohibited value of
the opinion will depend on whether from
all the evidence in the case you find
that those facts are true
you may in fact determine from the
evidence indicates that the facts that
form the basis of the opinion are true
or not true
or are true in part only and in light of
such findings you should decide what
effect such determination has upon the
weight to be given to the opinion of the
expert
your acceptance or rejection of the
expert opinion will depend therefore to
some extent on your findings as to the
truth of the facts alleged
that's essentially
what's laid out
in this limiting instruction
and that's the standard charge so i'm
not inclined to deviate from that
i mean i could put in the first part
certainly
which is essentially in there already
yeah i i think the second part is
covered by the standard expert charge
and that's not not just to the
psychiatrist but for any of the experts
all of their opinions are only as good
as the facts upon which they form their
opinion
all right now there's an optional charge
concerning compensation of experts
i don't think it came up with any of the
experts
all right um
then i'll charge testimony of character
witnesses
and
um that's the standard charge
i don't have their name specifically
i have to review my notes but
what's your recollection of who the
character witnesses were your honor i
believe the testimony of that nature
certainly came in with boyd martin
voyd martin
phillip dutton that's d-u-t-t-o-n
uh allison
brock
and i if i'm not mistaken to some extent
stephen tarshis
i don't remember clearly whether he went
beyond
uh you know for example i believe i
asked him
and my recollection is fun but i believe
i asked him whether or not uh michael
was ever
committed harm to a horse
it's not really character evidence
though
true character evidence is reputation
opinion
or a criminal conviction which doesn't
apply here but it's really just true
character evidence is reputation or
opinion
in my mind judge mr dutton and mr martin
were both certainly character witnesses
i think miss brock kind of blended
between a character and effect witness
and i don't recall mr tarshish really
he certainly talked about his his
knowledge of the defendant as did a
number of other witnesses but i think at
that point we start getting into we've
heard that testimony from mr franco from
his dancer
from mr hardin through his dread
i think ms cook gibbs gave some
kind of testimony along those lines
but i don't think they were true
character witnesses in the sense that
button martin and brock were
you aren't i'm satisfied if we use that
more you know brock your honor
and i don't think cook gibbs was really
a character witness
and just so i'm glad i don't either i
was just using her as an example of
another witness who testified to
sort of
reputational information that she was
aware of
not even sure brock gave
sufficient character testimony
at least not according to my notes
testified she lived in florida
laxahatchee florida
talked about being in
dressage
from being an equestrian for 25 years
member of the 2016 rio olympic team
seemed a bronze medal
mr barrissone was the coach she met him
in 2002.
and justin horton as well began to train
with mr marissan
saw him here and there
knew mr barrison is a close friend
august she was in florida
she received a phone call from jamie
dancer spoke to miss dancer for a couple
of minutes
as soon as she hung up she called
mr barrison
concerned that mr barrison would kill
himself
and then spoke to mr barrissone
said he was upset and sobbing
and i don't really see
too much character testimony do you have
anything different mr shellhorn or mr
dinan jerk
generally consistent with my nose
stretching
yeah uh it's consistent with my notes
right so i don't consider her to be a
true character witness
i may have said nice things about mr
barasson as a coach and things like that
but that's not
that's not really truly character
evidence under the rules
um
certainly mr uh
mr dutton was
and boyd martin certainly was
i think it's just those two would be
characterized as character witnesses
and that's just the the standard charge
now we get to the third part of the
instructions
anything else we need with regard to
specific types of evidence
i don't believe so judge not from my
perspective
all right so the third part
um
goes through the um
specific portions of the criminal code
that the jury has to apply to the facts
to determine whether the state has
proven the charges beyond a reasonable
doubt
there's a standard charge when there are
multiple charges as there are here
so i'll give that charge
and i'll lay out attempted murder counts
one and two
and there's a standard charge
i'll read the counts of the indictment
at that time
relevant statutes and then get into
the specifics of what has to be proven
and i'll just follow the standard charge
i'm not going to repeat it twice
obviously because counts one and two are
the same i'll just
i'm going to refer to counts one and two
and then when when i get into specifics
statements prove the following elements
beyond a reasonable doubt first it was
the defendant's purpose to cause the
death of lauren canorack
as alleged in count one
and robert goodwin
as alleged in count two
and secondly the defendant
purposely did or admitted to do anything
which under the circumstances as a
reasonable person would believe them to
be as an actor omission constituting a
substantial step
any course of conduct plan to culminate
in his causing the death of the victim
on defined purposely
to find a deadly weapon is included in
the charge as well
and the second element
is that the defendant did or omitted to
do anything
i know he charged mr shellhorn did or
admitted to do but i'm not sure the
omitted to do serves any purpose other
than perhaps confusing the jury when
they hear it and judge as you're even
saying this right now i would have no
objection to remember removing any
language about omitting to do anything i
don't think that
applies
i can't obviously remove it from the
indictment because that's what's charts
but
um
but from but from the charge i don't
have any objection to that
so
so anywhere
references omitted to do anything or
mission i'm gonna strike
any objection
mr blinkist any objection
um
all right then i'll get into counts
three and four and again i'll do the
same thing
so i don't have to repeat myself
before you move on to the other counts
uh when i had submitted a draft the
jury charges to the court i had
indicated uh
a possible lesser included offense of
aggravated assault
i know but um
i i plan on giving that
i'm just not sure where in the charge i
should give it because
i'm charging insanity obviously
if the jury accepts that
the defendant
was legally
insane they wouldn't consider any lesser
included offenses
they're not they're not gonna
say as to count one
i mean if if they find that he's insane
he's going to be insane on count one two
three and four they're not going to pick
and choose so i'm not sure they would
even get to a lesser included offense
if they believe that mr barrissone is
insane well i had i had left on your uh
bench as well as given to council this
morning a proposed verdict sheet that i
basically was modeled after what was on
the model uh verdict sheet on the
judiciary's website but i think that
at least the way i i'm proposing it
should be laid out on the verdict sheet
would be that the jury would consider
whether the defendant is guilty or not
guilty
of the crime of attempted murder just
using charge one as an example
and then also not guilty by reason of
insanity would be listed there if the
jury finds the defendant guilty of
attempted murder they move on to the
next charge if they find him not guilty
by reason of insanity of that charge
they move on to the next charge but if
they find him not guilty
then they would move on to consider a
lesser included offense
of aggravated assault of aggravated
assault
judge with regards to his verdict
guilty by reason of insanity be first
then not guilty
and then guilty which refers to lesser
included offense i don't think
my thought was
why i thought aggravated assault might
be appropriate
because
if the jury
does not believe mr barroson
was legally insane
at the time of the commission of the
offense that does not mean they can't
consider his mental state
in determining whether he acted
purposefully or knowingly in committing
the crime
in other words they may find he didn't
meet the threshold for legal insanity
but he did have a diminished capacity
because of
the stressors the circumstances
his depressive state
and the jury may find
it the testimony and circumstances
didn't arise to legal insanity
but they recognize that he was operating
with a diminished capacity
which may prevent him from
purposely or knowingly
or having a conscious object to commit
the murder of lauren cataract and robert
goodwin
that they would consider
a lesser charge of
recklessly
attempting to cause
the death uh or serious bodily injury to
lauren counteract or robert goodwin i
i've considered that too judge i think
that there's two parts to that question
though i think the pure lesser included
to attempted murder would be attempted
aggravated assault
because it's it's not a murder charge
it's an attempted murder so the the
charge the attempted aggravated assault
attempted aggravated assault i think
that what your honor is but you have
here in charge of aggravated assault i
did include it all there judge because i
do think there's a rational basis in the
in the record for it but i think because
but hold on but with regard to your
request for a charge of aggravated
assault
obviously there are different states of
mind for
aggravated assault you're not asking for
an attempted aggravated assault you're
just asking for the aggravated assault
well it's just the way that the
activated assault charges it talks about
attempt includes right it's included
right but i think that if in terms of
being intellectually
candid
the the true lesser included or the pure
lesser included to attempted murder
would be attempted aggravated assault it
would be an attempt theory of aggravated
attempt to call serious buy liens and we
do another yes it wouldn't necessarily
encompass as a pure lesser included
the actual commission whether it's
purposeful or or reckless or knowing
as your honor just discussed now i think
there's a rational basis for it in the
record but i don't think
i know but wouldn't i i'm in a position
to ask the court to give that
but you want the court to charge
aggravated assault of
as a lesser included
as to
both loren cataract and robert goodwin
on an attempt theory
right so the only charge would be if you
if they find
not guilty on
attempted murder
then they would consider the lesser
included offense of aggravated assault
but only
that he attempted to cause serious
bodily injury to
lauren cataract and an account to mr
goodwin yes
again unless not not the purposely or
knowingly and not
manifesting extreme indifference to
human life but
what what what what if they fought
i know but
what if
the jury finds
that
he went there
not with the conscious object
to kill
either one of them
right
didn't have the conscious object to kill
them
but they
find during the incident he did take out
the gun and shoot lauren cataract and
shot at mr goodwin
now could couldn't they find
even though it wasn't his conscious
object to kill that he
purposely or knowingly pointed the gun
and pulled the trigger
and tried to cause serious bodily injury
if it wasn't his conscious object to
actually kill them i know it's splitting
hairs but
juries have split hairs in the past when
i'm not trying to argue with the court
about your rationale i'm just saying i
think based on the way the indictment is
reading or reads it's an attempt theory
so as a pure lesser included i i can
only ask the court to charge on
something that's fairly included in the
indictment which i think would include
attacks
so i think there's definitely a
rationale so your position is if it's an
attempted murder card it's not
rationally included in that charge
all of the aggravated assault states of
mine only the attempt and that it
wouldn't be
purposely or knowingly
causing bodily injury
or recklessly well not that it's not
rationally included just that it whether
or not it's fairly included i don't want
to run into a potential issue on appeal
and i asked you to include something
that wasn't fairly included in the
indictment so all right so you're not
asking it so mr blinkist do you want
what's your position with regard to
lesser included offense of aggravated
assault
you don't think they're
rationally based in the record
in other words some of the evidence you
don't think a rational jury could find
charge of second-degree aggravated
assault as opposed to first-degree
attempted murder
that's the same theory that i've
discussed
with regards to
self-self-defense
which you've rejected
i i don't understand we're talking about
the defendant's state of mind with
regard to
i don't see how self-defense is any way
connected to the lesser included charge
the question is what was his state of
mind
at at the time because the
you you've introduced significant
psychiatric evidence
regarding the defendant's state of mind
and in fact i believe
one of the witnesses even mentioned on
the stand the term diminished capacity
may have been dr simmering
that actually mentioned that term and
there's no i believe that was dr
schlesinger that he
ruled that out
i don't believe uh
did mention
well i think it was before dr
schlesinger not not to throw a wrench in
this judge i actually think all the
doctors mentioned it in the sense that
they had
previously evaluated people and given
opinions about diminished capacity
insanity
i know but i remember a specific
reference i'll check my notes
i believe it was dr simmering that
actually used the term diminished
capacity
i i remember hearing it
partly because i was listening for it
and in these cases this case law when
if insanity evidence is presented
the jury could reject insanity but still
find
that the defendant because of
mental health issues could not form
the conscious object to kill someone
that would be the diminished capacity
and it would reduce the crime it's not
justification right doesn't doesn't
remove all
legal responsibility like insanity does
but it reduces the charge
from a higher level which has a
specific state of mind of
conscious object the intent to kill
and that diminished capacity
reduces the crime to a lesser crime
and it could be this this case loan i'll
i'll look for it i remember reading it
that that talks about specifically
if he couldn't form
the purpose or knowledge to kill a jury
could find that he acted recklessly in
shooting the individuals it's a
different state of mind but under the
circumstances diminished capacity that
he recklessly
committed the shooting and the jury if
they think he had a diminished state of
mind and couldn't form the intent to
kill they nevertheless could find you
know brandishing a firearm with that
circumstances and all the tension in the
toxic environment was reckless
i agree that the law says all about
judges
right
well i i guess the question is if
if there's an aggravated assault charge
as a lesser included
you're saying just logically
it should be
just the attempt
to cause serious bodily injury
from your viewpoint i think that's the
only lesser included
that would be
fairly included within the indian
lesser included
but
if the court decides to charge the
diminished capacity
there would be another possibility
that a jury could find
notwithstanding what's included that
based on the diminished capacity
evidence
that the defendant acted recklessly
under circumstances manifesting extreme
indifference to the
value of human life recklessly caused
serious bodily injury
and i think that's where the cases judge
talk about whether there's a rational
basis in the record or not
for the court to find
and i'm just looking at 2c 1-8 and some
of the comments there
about submission suicide by the court
where neither the prosecution or defense
requests a lesser including defense
charge
the facts of the case clearly indicate
there's a rational basis for the jury to
convict a lesser included offense that
must be charged by the judge even
without a request i think that's where
your honor is
what your honor is indicating
which is why i'm not taking a position
one way or the other
on that
all right mr blinkist what's your
position with regard to the lesser
included offenses
both as
requested by mr shellhorn
with regard to
the attempted
the attempt to cause serious bodily
injury as being
included
in the attempted murder charges in
counts one and two
why
because i don't think
the evidence before the jury
addresses of that issue
either he went down there
with the intent to kill
them
and is guilty of
attempted murder or
he's not guilty by reasonable insanity
what about if the jury rejects insanity
but finds that he couldn't form the
intent
to kill
you're saying i shouldn't charge
aggravated assault that he acted
recklessly because of his diminished
capacity
so
so
okay
so
all right
i'll consider the positions of council
the state requests a lesson included on
counts one and two
on counts one and two of um
second degree aggravated assault based
on attempt to cause serious bodily
injury
okay
and that's really without without regard
to the
diminished capacity correct
the defense doesn't want any lesser
included offenses is that correct mr
malinkas
and that's part of your strategy in this
case
it's a strategic decision on your part
correction i don't believe there's
evidence in the record to
support that
despite the
mental health evidence presented by your
experts
you think that can only be used by the
jury to go into insanity and not not to
consider lesser included offenses
yes
you have any case law that supports that
position
all right
one quote we'll give i'll make a
decision
either later today or over the weekend
on
those lesser included offenses
i will give the standard charge on
insanity
from the model
criminal jury charges
and in the model charge it specifically
references the three verdicts
in the charge you may return one of
three verdicts one not guilty two guilty
three not guilty by reason of insanity
that's the order i'll maintain on the
verdict sheet
and i'll do uh further research on the
charts related to evidence of
mental
disease or defect that is diminished
capacity
and that's set forth in
criminal code
2c colon 4-2 evidence of mental disease
or defect admissible and relevant to
element of the offense
evidence that the defendant suffered
from a mental disease or defect is
admissible whenever
it is relevant to prove that the
defendant did not have a state of mind
which is an element of the offense
in the absence of such evidence
may be presumed that the defendant had
no mental disease or defect which would
negate a state of mind which is an
element of the offense
hmm
mr shellhorn do you have a position with
regard to the so-called diminished
capacity
what do you want time to read that
section familiar with it and certainly
if your honor
is comfortable that dr simmering
testified to that i was also listening
to it or for it i don't recall hearing
it
i'm not i'm not even sure he has to
specifically say that
because it says evidence
that the defendant suffered from a
mental disease or defect is admissible
whenever it's relevant to poor the
defendant and not have a state of mind
a relevant state of mind
so in other words my view was a jury
could
could find
that
mr barryson was not insane at the time
legal
insanity and therefore they're not going
to find them not guilty by reason of
insanity
but then the question is
are we going to preclude the jury from
considering his
mental state
in light of the testimony from the
doctors
i i think the issue that i
am having with your honor is that none
of the doctors testified
that the defendant recalled or was uh
indicated anything about the
circumstances of what he was thinking at
the time
which i think would be the direct
question your honor is asking whether he
was asking acting purposely knowingly or
recklessly
and so if all the doctors say we either
asked him or didn't ask him but we have
no way of knowing
why he did what he did
then i don't know that they could really
opine that his
state of mind or ability to form
a purposeful or knowing state of mind
was affected because of his mental
health issues or his diagnosis
as compared to for example if the
defendant were to have said
i went there
i had the gun for self-protection i saw
the look on someone's face and that led
me to believe delusionally they were
going to kill me
and so i acted
that may
have affected the doctor saying well
that was not a purposeful state of mind
it was a lesser state of mind i think so
i think maybe that's the
part of the psychiatric testimony that
is missing to me
that would support a diminished capacity
okay
um
and not to belabor the point judge but i
think that both dr simran and both both
dr simran and dr hassan testified
that the defendant
delusion was that he was going to be
killed he went there
in an effort to act in self-defense
which i think what they're saying is
that that would indicate a purposeful
state of mind perhaps purposeful and
justified in the way that they're saying
it but
purposeful as opposed to something else
and because there's no statement from
the defendant
that could be interpreted
differently in that regard
but i could be
reading it too literally
uh
um
all right mr shellhorn
i think in your comments whether you
knew it or not you were referring to
state versus rivera
228
it says when there is no request towards
the minutes diminished capacity and
there's no request from the defense
and no part of the psychiatric testimony
referred specifically to the effect of
the defendant's mental condition on the
ability to know he was committing murder
there was no need to charge diminished
capacity
i was actually almost reading that exact
line when i was just talking judge yes
i didn't realize that was a citation but
yes
i'll have to review my notes regarding
the witness testimony but it's your
recollection
that none of the doctors
opined on
his ability to know he was committing
murder
that was my recollection yes judge
do you have it in mind
what all right i'll review the evidence
and mr barrissone
are you in agreement with your council's
position
well have you discussed it with him in
detail
about the about the charge of diminished
capacity
yes he's in quantity and whatever mr
says
what
the reason why i asked that because if i
if i don't charge it and the jury
doesn't accept
insanity
they may convict you of attempted murder
which obviously is a higher charge than
the second degree aggravated assault
all right i need to do a little more
research on the issue
but i have the position of the parties
in that regard
[Applause]
i think that's generally it i'll give
the standard charge on deliberations
united in his verdict
over the jury form jury questions things
of that nature
all right anything else counsel judge i
think you mentioned this and then we
started talking about the lesser
included offense but you're also going
to just give the standard charge on
possession of a firearm for an unlawful
purpose yeah
and do it the same way
yeah reference count three pertains to
unlawful purpose to use it against
lauren counteract count for unlawful
purpose to use it against robert goodwin
and i'll give the standard charge judge
on page five of the standard charge
it talks about the allegation with
respect to the
defendant's unlawful purpose
it's it says in this case the city time
the second would you um
i'm sorry all right so the first element
is
that exhibits whatever is a firearm
what's what's the specific exhibit that
our references
all right so the first element is the
firearm exhibit s177 is a firearm the
second element
the defendant possessed a firearm
knowing intentional control
so um
define knowingly what knowledge is
and uh possession means a conscious
knowing possession
either actual or constructive
yes in this case the state contends
and what was your point in that regard
judge i had suggested in what i
submitted to the court previously that
the defendant's purpose in possessing
the firearm was to use it to shoot
lauren canorack and or robert goodwin
but i think that was the only place
really that called for any uh
any suggested additional names okay all
right we'll just make reference to that
the purpose to use it to shoot lauren
cataract
as regards to count one and shoot
robert goodwin as it pertains to count
two
all right
anything else
counseling you want added
i don't believe so judge no well mr
balance
just for the record so it's
well
just so the record is clear since we're
having a charge conference what what is
your basis for
asserting
that
self-defense through the use of deadly
force should be charged to this jury
what what evidence in the record can you
point to
and what what evidence is there that
that occurred
prior
to the shooting and that
mr barristone utilized the gun either
during or
after
the shooting
uh the beating
to protect himself
as i have
previously indicated
the
only evidence with regards to the timing
of the shooting comes from both cataract
and goodwin
i believe there's ample evidence in the
record as both of them have survived
with regards to
this incident
their testimony i submit is completely
improbable
nearly impossible
if the beating occurred before the
shooting and he was
not allowed to get a response
based on the court's objection so
um i i believe there is addicted
evidence particularly in light of all
the previous threats
that
were made
in the incident the day before where
robert goodwin had
made a
gesture with his finger
as a gun
what was the immediacy of mr barriston
arming himself and going to the
farmhouse
because this is deadly force
right and there's there's got to be
there's got to be a reasonable belief
that force is necessary to protect
themselves
and you have an individual who arms
himself
and drives to a location
a quarter mile away from
the clubhouse
or armed with a weapon
so how is there a reasonable belief on
his part that force is necessary
with all the threats that she had made
leading up to that all the social media
posts where she threatened to kill him
and mary haskins
it could be argued that he believed
it was necessary if he was going to have
any contact with with her
to arm
what was his purpose in going there
that's not there's nothing on the record
about that i want the jury to speculate
about why he went up to the house that
day he went there to try to work this
out
he said specifically
can't we work this out i know and where
is that evidence
from how is it from him how is it from
that's from robert goodwin
right their testimony so
so that part is accurate but what
follows is not in your view
witness can lie about different portions
of their story
she certainly didn't come down
um
you know and
and say anything threatening according
to
her
them
is clear
she came out she was angry
she she approached him it's been
described as her stomping towards him
it's my belief that
their testimony
is not going to be believed
and
i think it's appropriate
mr shellhorn judge only if you need to
hear from me
no i i don't think there is sufficient
evidence in the record
for a self-defense charge in
self-protection
first the defendant armed himself
according to the evidence
from a weapon he obtained
on the second i believe so
four or five days before
and when the dcp and p worker came
she testified that mr barrisson
came into the room where she was talking
to miss
haskins gray
on three separate occasions
there was no cross-examination of that
witness
by mr blanca so her testimony is
essentially
unrefuted
and that
it's unrefuted i don't believe it's
unrefuted because the medical experts
all testify that's not substantive
evidence
you can't argue that if you're planning
on arguing that in summation don't even
put it in your notes
it's not substantive evidence
mr barrison's statements to the experts
i will charge i went over that charge
they are not substantive evidence
you cannot use his statements to make
any substantive arguments to the jury
they only go
and they're only admissible
as it pertains
to his state of mind
as determined by the experts that's what
the charge says
you cannot use mr barrison's statements
that to experts to refute the testimony
of the dcp worker that would be using
the evidence substantively
it can't be done
it's not proper
and that's why i said the testimony is
unrefuted
there was no cross-examination
and the witness
said mr barrison came in three times
asked them to leave on the third time he
was insistent
the worker even said mr barrissone
kissed miss haskins gray
when they were leaving the room
and a clear import from that testimony
is that he wanted to retrieve the gun
because
he immediately left
drove up to the farm while armed
and then there was a
confrontation
mr goodwin spoke to him
and then miss canorack came out
and even if the jury
doesn't believe everything that miss
canorack or mr goodwin said about the
incident
they would be engaging in this court's
view and sheer speculation
to
determine that the beating happened
before the gun was withdrawn and that mr
barristone withdrew the gun as a result
of the beating
and use it in self-defense
that would just be
pure speculation
there's no evidence in the record
they may do cross-examination
that was to impeach their credibility
so
to the extent that they were impeached
does not mean
the jury has evidence
from which in the record from which they
can rationally find that the beating
happened before
and that mr barrison took out the gun
because he believed reasonably believed
he was in imminent danger
and needed the weapon
but it was necessary for him to shoot
twice at miss cataract in the chest to
protect himself
it's even further speculation
given nature of the testimony
that he took a shot that went through
the porch door
and into the house
a jury would have to speculate
as to the reason for that shot being
fired
without the testimony of mr barrissone
about the incident this
simply no evidence in the record
and it's not sufficient
for the jury to make that determination
simply from
the cross cross-examination by mr
blinkis
there's simply insufficient evidence in
the record
to support the
self-defense
charge so it will not be given
and i might say the self-defense charge
would be
contrary to the testimony of dr
simmering
the defense expert
we found that the defendant's need for
self-defense was a delusion
on his part
i do find is no substantive efforts
substantive evidence in this case to
support
the thesis that the defendant acted in
self-defense
it would simply be speculation by the
jury
so it won't be charged all right
anything else
thank you i'll try to
finish this by this afternoon and send a
charge
to you for your review over the weekend
yes i just want to
mark for the record
uh
the
handwritten
notes
of mr barisson 983
what's the purpose of marking that
document
just because various things in there i
was excluded from getting into
and i just want the record to be
complete
which specific things
about michael barrasson knowing
that
robert goodwin and warren canara were
searching
for trying to contact the small children
prior to the shooting on social
all right media
that that document the problem with that
document it was drafted after he was
incarcerated
after discovery had been turned over
so the fact that it's in a document
doesn't indicate mr barrisson knew it
beforehand
well what what the record doesn't show
is when exactly that was drafted i think
i think i think i think we
are you in agreement that it was drafted
after mr barrissone after the shooting
not before
and after he was incarcerated
yes
what are the numbers
so the first one is uh
800-92 it's this uh we only have a small
copy of it it's the
i'm gonna come over and take a look at
what witness was that shown to i don't
remember
witness
seeing a small photograph
should these are these are the
photographs
that were done of the crime scene and i
was going to do the impression that we
were stipulating to all these things
i don't necessarily have an objection to
the photo if it was shown to a witness
but i just don't recall a witness if it
was shown to a witness that's fine but
if it wasn't shown to a witness it's not
going in
it still has to be some testimony about
it
let me see the photograph really it's a
close-up of one of his pictures
can we agree that these already
record
uh
i thought
okay
uh no not at this time we already talked
we moved this one in yesterday that
lauren cataract marked one right yeah
but that's all you guys have thought
well i also need to notice this one
i'm
all right great
thank you
you already think we've resolved those
issues
yeah so my position on that picture at
the bench judge is that if there was
testimony about it i don't object to it
and if i may approach
this is uh just for the record it's 88
892. 800-92
if that if there was testimony on that i
have no objection to it
judge it was my
understanding that
i stipulated to all the photographs the
prosecutor
needed to injure
deuce
and they were in the same stack and it
was my impression that
i would be able to put that in
virtually
a
picture
that's a close-up of one of his shots
but i
i hesitate to admit it if it wasn't
shown to a witness even if there is a
stipulation because they would have to
identify it or give some testimony about
it i i think that's where i'm coming
from judges that
i wouldn't ask for any testimony just
did you take this picture does it
accurately depict it i know but still
it's part of it just part of the trial
record if that's in evidence then
there's no
there's no reference by any witness to
the photograph
right i don't know how in other words i
think judge the jury would have to have
some testimony about what the picture is
and what's going on in the picture which
is what i did with all right they were
they were shown they've seen it moved
into evidence and the other ones
regarding the injuries were shown to the
jury they saw those this was never
shown to show to a witness or shown to
the jury during any part of the trial so
i don't think i can admit it for that
reason
sure
see you on monday
thank you ryan and whatever can i see
those other photographs so when i know
what
is being admitted for the record
i need all the numbers
my staff needs the numbers too
so
let me approach just read them out for
the for the rest of 800-3
another that was admitted is 800-42
800-52
800-56
800-66
800-64
and 800-55
and lastly your honor defense exhibit
500-5
which is a
notice of violations
yes
i believe that's all correct john all
right all right those are all admitted
in evidence
okay